how are you it's got to be a tough time
for the family right now
is what you know what we get through it
what do you stand because the family's
divided is divided as they've ever been
yeah where do you stand
I know how they've raised us and I know
the values that they've taught us
so if they've taught us those values it
means they have them so do you believe
Sidhu you so you believe your mom and
dad at this point I mean let's let's
talk about the extortion claims right I
need to the fact that your father could
be trying to do to extort them the sex
tape we know they didn't make a sex tape
because it was probably the doggy cam is
there any truth to those
you know I don't want to speak on it too
much but what I can say is it's
extremely sad that someone is using the
sex tape that doesn't even exist in
order to get my more minutes of things
[Applause]
it is what it is I know that my dad has
never so there is no there is no sex
table no has your father ever seen this
I mean it's just it's just it's just
it's just like that's one thing it's a
little weird right you know that that
your father would give his daughter sex
tape and then try to get money on he
would try to help her but cuz that
should be something that
you should be embarrassed so well you
should maybe be in very few made a sex
tape that's one thing but they're saying
it didn't make you sex tape that it was
caught on the doggy cam right and look
if you put a camera in my house right
the things that go on in my house right
and you repeat kind of weird here is
probably the same thing right so you're
saying there is no sex because your
father and chase could do a lot of time
in prison stuff to back it up so it's
just they're not in an option was sad
that my dad has a child of his but it's
trying to make his life so miserable
just because she wasn't on the show and
she didn't get
in the family recover from this I mean
this is serious and I know she said that
she's open to repairing the relationship
can your family recover from these these
allegations are really scandalous I can
say for me personally
but you'll never forgive your sister
over this no matter what
is your father open to forgiving of
children or different and siblings
I've got siblings that I don't talk to
you and I will never talk to again
parents are different your father
which shows the kind of person that he
is
and she needed something tomorrow urs he
would he would help her
with all this
one of the human beings I've ever met so
what he decided to do was on
and I can have the relationships that I
want to have and you just can't have
people what's her endgame
what's Lindsey's endgame is she want to
see her father in prison do you think
that's what it's looking like so it's
sad but the truth always wins
the triskin one so so let me let me ask
you this you said for this they won't go
to prison the tax evasion charges are
they could do prison time for that too
you know I don't know
I know as my parents have always
encouraged us to do the right thing so
if they're encouraging us to do the
right thing then
how worried are you for your freedom
parents at this point this is this is a
scary time this isn't look sure you guys
are we had television personalities and
you live your lives on television but
this is
trying to serious thing here how worried
are you for your
[Music]
heartbreaking to see mr. Brindisi
one of their children have contributed
to it so it's extremely sad and
the truth always wins which our fiance
thing is like now man I I'm marrying
into this crazy batshit crazy family
what does he what does he think
extremely supportive
all right final question all of this
drama it's some serious drama there's a
make for better reality television let's
be honest
shouldn't we ration you guys just wrap
all of that into sextortion the tax
evasion claims a family drama wrap it up
into into one show so you think you
address all those issues on the show
so you stand by Chase as well what's
your message to your sister at this
point if you could give her a message
any messages I know you said you're the
relationships down what's your message
to Lin
let go of the hard feelings I am
I wish nothing but the best for her but
she needs to focus on herself instead of
trying to tear them you love her you'll
never forgive her Robbie says he has
messages from Chase and this and that
and the other
you know it says the truth always wins
and
[Music]
[Applause]